[Music]
you guys know those those type of people
that like to dress
vintage yeah it's pretty hyper yeah
right like it's so cool but usually
it's like um yeah i guess it like it
depends like which era
my dad dresses vintage he wears stuff
from like the 70s and 80s
that's cool i have family who wear kkk
hoods
that is vintage it's it's old school
getting in touch with the roots
yeah still around oh true don't you need
like good like door clearance to walk
through
yeah yeah yeah how do they keep it yeah
it's not a popular fashion choice you
have to hang it upside down people don't
know this but when you're driving you
have to starch it
okay and you plug it in and you go like
seriously i thought they were wearing
like a cone
like an angel thing like a circle and no
like they gel their hair and then they
just pull it out
it's got framework to it you get to get
a post yeah it's like
it's like a [ __ ] you're building a tent
good that's sturdy anyway so
this story here is about mila she is
from ukraine and she decided okay so
about 12 years ago
she joined this one particular club
where it's like a historical
reconstruction club where those members
they were passionate about
medieval nightly combat oh [ __ ] she
joined this that's when she started
becoming
very like fascinated with historical
garments and so during that time
she was she would sew costumes for
various festivals and battle
reenactments
and so she used all kinds of different
old engravings and
paintings as a guide and so that allowed
her to study the history of fashion
first hand
and allowed her to learn how to sew
garments for herself so she wears like
leather underwear
no she just smells like it
[Laughter]
she's actually into the the 19th century
era of fashion so she abandoned the
medieval times yeah no that wasn't
like she she wasn't really 19th century
means 1800
right yeah the most confusing [ __ ]
thing that humanity ever made i know
you take away 20th century fox means
21st century fox and then they became
21st century fox and like [ __ ] it
and they got bought by the mouse anyway
but it's so confusing well because the
first century is the the zero century
yeah
yeah that's just how it works dude but
it's still confusing
yeah because when we're born it's not
like we're like
one year our first year is not when
we're one yeah yeah
it's like as [ __ ] up as celsius
the entire metric system like oh it's 30
degrees celsius i'm like oh no but we're
the only ones that use fahrenheit out
here fahrenheit is the [ __ ] up one to
be honest the uk and the
i think uk doesn't use fahrenheit
how come i don't know we went to war
with so many countries we didn't even
change the [ __ ] metric system back
yeah we should have [ __ ] them up and
like now you're using inches [ __ ]
actually
you measure your dick like this now yeah
i'm not in stone i feel like now i'm
only five and a half
i was 10 in metrics oh actually it's uh
bahamas
palau belize cayman islands the
federated states of micronesia the
marshall islands the united states
and its territories such as puerto rico
virgin islands and guam
i like how you said um actually first um
i did yeah it was good
that actually you did actually anyway
back to this chick
so this is mila mila mila
neil she's so she got that mary poppins
look that's exactly what i thought about
that's the new mary poppins too it
reminds me of mary
poppins that's that mark twain swag
right yeah
you look she's so is that victorian yes
victorian time that's dope yeah and so
she looks good in it yeah she looks
really good and so she makes her own
her own stuff and she ends up going to
like uh flea markets
and places like that to get actual like
authentic like for example shoes or
some of her purses or her hats so
accessories
it's cute if you if you like live where
she's walking around with like
cobblestone roads and [ __ ] but like
imagine just going to like mcdonald's
with her
oh yeah she dresses like this every day
yeah like her man's
dressed as normal she goes like that to
like la fitness and stuff too
ukraine oh ukraine fitness it does kind
of match
because yeah like you said like in
europe a lot of the buildings
it looks like that right oh yeah yeah
she does take photos
in front of things that complement her
look
and um yeah so it's just really
interesting to see
oh she also has like this tic-tac page
where because i was looking scrolling
through her page
and she has these tick tocks where it
shows like a sped-up version
of her putting on just her undergarments
wow
and it's like a process there's a lot of
layers how long does it take her
i don't know is that why they don't they
don't get cold back then like they look
like they don't have that many layers on
but they actually do you have a lot yeah
so she wears a corset every day too oh
damn
yeah but for her she says it's
comfortable because she got it custom
made to her body so it's not
uncomfortable but yeah what's her summer
wear
yeah what's her bathing suit well like i
just imagine her friends being like all
right let's go to the club this weekend
don't invite
um
she's gonna be embarrassing us at the
table yeah starts from 3 p.m
look at hillary imagine her twerking in
those dresses do you think it took that
long
look at that bump oh okay you think that
was pretty normal it took that
long to get ready back then and then she
even shows like how she does her hair
and that's a process
all the ladies did that yeah she says
that it takes her a lot longer obviously
to get ready but she does it every day
and as soon as she's in
in this this wardrobe she just feels a
lot better
so how do they get housework done oh
there's even one tick tock where it
shows like the day of the week and it's
like
oh monday go to the market and it shows
like the outfit she would wear if she's
like
going to the market or um like tuesday
go to a day in the village or some [ __ ]
what's funny is that girls really
experienced this like two times in the
life
prom wedding day true whereas back then
it was every day um girl's got a
concealer
in the kitchen i was gonna bring it up
shout out to mexican culture
i mean it's definitely cute she looks
good i feel bad for them they gotta work
so hard to put on clothes
i guess she likes it she loves right
yeah i don't feel bad for her she's
doing it on purpose she's for fun
does she ever take breaks like she's
like i'm gonna wear a [ __ ] you know
a hoodie today this is her purse it's
coveted i have to be inside i'm gonna
wear sweats
she can't wear a [ __ ] mask she's
gotta wear uh
what was the other pandemic where they
had the bird mask where's she has
the bubonic plague walking around with
the bird [ __ ]
[Laughter]
because they used to think that bad
smell is what caused disease
interesting did she say that she does
this during covid i don't know
cause there's no [ __ ] way well i i
saw her instagram page and she's still
posting photos like this so she's
probably wearing these
shorts covered in cat hair like my wife
t-shirts
so so from the waist up it's yeah just
for the pictures right look at the end
of the day all that matters that she has
followers now
she has growing a growing instagram page
did your grandma's like
were they stuck in the 30s or whatever
oh my grandma was stuck in the 60s it
was so cool her whole
wardrobe like till this day i go into
her closet and she has so many 60 items
because she was
she loved accessories and so many shoes
and purses
she's a lifestyle she's still alive yeah
my mom's stuck in the 70s and 80s
her clothes look like 70s and 80s my
grandma disco shirts and [ __ ]
my mama's yeah it's pretty disco-e my
mom is stuck in depression
the great the great one yeah oh there
you go the great one
that's not what i meant but i know it's
okay nobody listens to her anyway so
it's similar to that
yeah my mom my mom's just the same as
when i look like pictures of her
pregnant [ __ ] but it's
it's like loose flannels and like uh
nothing actually [ __ ] that's kind of
trendy now i think yeah everything
is bad yeah yeah i have a baby picture
with her when she's holding me
and she wears the same freaking top hey
good for hershey and rockets though
that's true you guys should recreate
them yeah recreate the picture
oh that'll be hilarious she is like
holding me like that and then the next
picture is it's like she's holding me
like that
that was actually uh a tick-tock
challenge oh really
you wearing that hat helps and visualize
everything
baby that's true it's not that far off i
feel like you should recreate your
your little wait i forget is it the
brown suit was that you
yeah yeah on top of the rock yeah i
could go to that old house too maybe the
rock is still there oh cool
you're gonna have some grown-ass dude in
a suit on top of the rock
wait what's the for the context oh baby
picture of him it's back there you're
gonna get it cool
yeah cause we need the contest we always
assume everyone has seen everything
and it's a mistake but then when we tell
the same story twice and everyone gets
mad too
yeah everyone's like we've heard this a
million times so then that's when we get
into that like
oh they already know like steve we know
your mom's depressed i'm like well sorry
i was trying to talk about it again i
know that your sister's hot
i for sure told the same stories on here
like three times yeah but i also do that
in my regular
content too because you know what i'm
saying like i've i just always
now that all my content is very
conversation based whether it's the
podcast or the mukbangs i'm constantly
repeating stories we all have podcasts
we all come on here
yeah we all go on each other's podcasts
what
yeah someone took it okay so describe it
for us
i'm in a business suit and i'm standing
on top of a brown business how old are
you
[ __ ] i don't know you look like four or
five yeah
yeah i was still pudgy damn you had a
suit at four years old that's it yeah i
had a suit
for you [ __ ] bowl cut yup yeah bowl
cut mm-hmm
you look like you're i had a bowl okay
we all had a bowl cut yeah
yeah you probably had one too i did
actually it was bold in spanish
that's not it i've never said that in my
life wait how do you spell it
c-u-n-c-o right c-u-e i knew it started
with a c
i failed spanish four times guys i i
remember some things
quick something so you gotta and how you
say hairstyle
i've never said cuenco in my life well
you've never eaten out of a bowl
we had bowls i think we just called
flatus anyway i don't know whatever
i forgot but the point is this lady
dresses like in the 19th century i think
it's tight
i want to dress old what era would you
choose all
eras oh man i don't even know which ones
to choose they're so cool
i want to come here in my samurai outfit
next time yeah
i almost got to get up but i don't have
the undergarments can you
sit in it though because it looks very
uncomfortable i haven't thought about
that
disneyland when they were open they had
a yearly dapper day
where everybody would dress like old
school like suspenders
and like [ __ ] like that yeah yeah i've
always wanted to go i want to dress like
different
i think if i'm hella rich that's what
i'll do i'll just come in here one day
i'll look like a like [ __ ] martin
luther
not the uh martin luther king but the
original
uh famous martin luther in germany like
a like a monk
like with the [ __ ] like friar tuck
[ __ ] oh fire attack would have been an
easier
reference that's true because i do know
what martin luther looks like he has
like a little like a beret like
hat on oh okay every time i watch a ryan
gosling movie i'm like i'm gonna start
wearing more suits and comb my hair more
and then i [ __ ] never do well because
then when we do we're like i don't look
like ryan
yeah yeah at all damn it that's cause we
gotta live in
in europe or something that's where they
really rock it and it's hot as [ __ ] over
here
it's super nice and everyone is dressed
like that yeah so you don't stand out
yeah
we should have a dress update i don't
see anyone dressing like shakespeare
with the krusty the clown thing going on
around their neck true
i get the occasional comment when like
where they're like dude why you still
dressed like you're in high school and
i'm like honestly dog like
i rap and i make youtube videos for a
living i'm gonna dress like this until
i'm 80 bro
how are you supposed to drive you're
like how about because i act like i'm so
nice
[Laughter]
the facts what videos are you watching
the man
of me i don't see anybody scolding snoop
dogg
no exactly yeah like hey snoop dogg how
come you dress
like you're not old
yes noob look at snoop dogg trying to
dress cool i know look at him
who says that
[Music]